hey guys it's justine and today we are
testing out the new iphone 12 pro i'm
gonna take some photos and some videos
but first thank you to dbrand for
sponsoring this video because i just put
on
their new tempered glass screen
protector and this thing
is it just blew my mind new iphones mean
new
dbrand skins we also have one of their
cases but we also have something new we
have their new
tempered glass screen protector and why
this is very exciting is because the new
iphone 12 is a completely flat display
so it will allow for some very precise
placement of these screen protectors you
might be saying justine yeah but the new
iphone 12 has
new ceramic shield which is four times
stronger than the previous iphone 11 yes
it is but it is about the same
as far as scratch resistance so i do not
want to make the same mistake that i did
last year by not putting a screen
protector on mine so we're starting off
this iphone 12
right i mean they even give you a little
screen
bubble pusher
[Music]
wow this is perfect
oh my god it's not even scratching it at
all i just thought okay i'll stab it and
if it does scratch it
cool great i have another one i'll put
that one on
i'm so impressed let's get a case on
this thing
look at that that looks good
oh did you need to de-brand your mag
safe
you can do that too
god that's great okay back on that one
back on the iphone tyler's here hi tyler
and like i've said before the biggest
difference between the 12
and the 12 pro is the 12 does not have a
telephoto lens and you can only shoot in
30 frames a second as opposed to the 60
frames
dolby vision hdr so let's uh let's go
take some photos and videos yes i
still have a sprained ankle so let's
we're gonna take this real slow
it is so beautiful out it just rained so
it feels
so fresh it's so fresh what is that is
that a person
or is that a that is a person's feet are
they flipping are they
yes they're doing some sort of they're
doing some sort of activity
should we take a picture of these people
one thing that i wouldn't be able to do
if i was shooting this on the 12
is there's no telephoto but i'll be able
to see them
[Music]
so i'm using the osmo mobile 4 to
stabilize my shot as i'm walking
this already has really incredible
stabilization but just having this added
gimbal to get these shots makes it look
so much cooler
the one thing that i am excited to show
you guys though is the difference
between the hdr footage on the 12 pro
and the 11 because right now you're not
actually able to see the hdr because i'm
exporting this video in sdr but when you
are really taking this into final cut
you're able to see the color detail
you're able to see how much more color
you
it's windy again
they just asked who i was talking to um
i'm talking to my friends
on youtube so because i'm posting this
on youtube it is an sdr clip you're not
going to really be able to see the
difference but when you do take this
into final cut comparing the footage
between the 12
and the 11 there is such a huge
difference because you have so much more
color detail you have the ability to
bring up and down the highlights
so much more than you could in the
non-hdr footage so a lot of you guys
keep saying but it looks the same
i promise you as someone who has edited
this video and other ones
it is not the same
[Music]
the front-facing camera is also amazing
because they have
added an update to this so you will be
able to do front facing
night mode which is kind of cool i
haven't really got to test it out as
much as i'd like
i did a little bit but sometimes when it
is really dark i
just use the flash to get a good selfie
but the fact that they have added night
mode on all of these lenses
is pretty cool speechless
like it just takes a good photo every
single time
that's a nice photo that's a nice photo
that wasn't
[Music]
do
[Music]
hey bird
everything in ultrawide just looks
terrifying this looks like i'm at the
grand canyon right now
i'm not spoiler
[Music]
let's get that wide angle
i found a rock it's pretty
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's night time which means it's night
mode time
night mode is available on every single
camera on the iphone 12
and it's only on the wide angle on the
iphone 11. since the sun just went down
it's not
really dark enough to really show you
guys how incredible i mode
you are going to shut up you're going to
shut your mouth now
obviously night mode handheld is pretty
good
but the tripod night mode is where this
really shines
let's go find some darkness not that i
don't love a good industrial roof or
[Music]
anything
oh god
[Music]
i'm so scared i'm not going to sleep
tonight
[Music]
i'm never going to be able to sleep ever
again
that's a lie but it is really spooky
[Music]
oh
oh i can't wait to see this
look at the difference you can actually
see the clouds moving because it was
able to take a 30 second shot wow
well i think you guys get the point
ultra wide
night mode on the iphone 12 is
incredible all right i'm hungry let's
we're done with this video now
[Music]
you